I'm breakable Kimmy Schmidt is coming
back for a musically packed season two
on Netflix and the stars couldn't help
but sing about their excitement to et in
best friends all right keep let's keep
going there's so much music in season
two I'm so excited it's so much music
it's so good because as I say Carol Jane
and Titus are actual musicians who are
professional Broadway actors and it
would be a shame to not include music
and yeah but so far it's really fun to
watch you
it's venture to you while you make a
wonderful attempt that Kitty and bunny
stuff is so funny it's so funny
it's it wanted his own ate solving
mysteries one hug at a time money and
candy two of it
how are we gonna top Pinot Noir well
let's see don't I don't know that it's
about topping as much as it is about
exploring the other areas of music that
we can investigate and offer up that
latch on to and make their own just like
they did with yes would piano it's a
journey not a destination
oh yeah I'm making a music video it's
called Pinot Noir an ode to black penis
how many people come up to you and say
please sing this to me
people got it so funny everyone thinks
if people ask me to sing it to them
people sing it to me Oh infinitely worse
good so much so I I never and I actually
couldn't because I don't remember I
don't I don't have a middle ear I don't
know the lyrics I realized since II
don't know
why